well someone in North Korea read the art
of the deal North Korea is threatening
to cancel next month's summit between
Kim jong-un and president Trump over
military drills going on right now
involving the u.s. and South Korea that
is so Donald now this shocks the media
but if you just read one sentence from
Trump's book you'd know that
negotiations don't proceed without such
antics and more will come and it's not
like Trump didn't prepare you for it
let's see what happens we're moving
along very nicely with North Korea we'll
see what happens
taking a long time many many decades to
get here let's see what happens we're
doing very well on as you know North
Korea we'll see what happens so we will
see what happens we haven't seen
anything we haven't heard anything we
will see what happens
we'll see what happens we'll see what
happens that montage was for those who
think Trump's being played or hopes that
he's being played better he looks a fool
than brings world peace right media this
was utterly predictable once the
president was so eager to accept the
terms before the terms were even spelled
out is it possible Kim jong-un realizes
he got everything he's already wanted
which is recognition on the world stage
did President Trump
do you believe make a mistake in all of
his optimism about his upcoming summit
with kim jeong-hoon wet blankets point
is we all come at this with heavy
skepticism with Trump we trust he's not
full of rosy optimism driven by selfish
legacy this is a guy who wields a real
stick not just a yummy carrot which is
why there's real reason to be optimistic
even with the North Korea's threats hell
I'd be more uncertain without such
threats it's a sign of engagement
granted for this deal to happen you have
to think big and believe you can
actually pull it off take away smaller
achievement Wollman Rink a man had an
attraction that languished for years
because the city couldn't get it running
Trump got involved in in months turned
it into a wildly popular tourist
attraction so why did that happen
because some guy thought he could do it
do not underestimate the
power of positive thinking especially
when it's coming from someone who knows
the good guys from the bad and how to
speak both their languages and look
haven't we seen results already today
North Korea threatened to cancel a
meeting months ago they were threatening
to nuke us I call that progress Dana
Dana Dana isn't this how this works well
when you're dealing with the North
Koreans I think so yes certainly that we
don't know a lot about Kim jong-un
because it's called the Hermit Kingdom
for a season and I do think that there's
gonna be some curveballs along the way I
do think that the president has been
pretty cautious he's been optimistic and
throwing some cold water on it at the
same time in almost everything that he
says not every time so if there's
criticism about that I think that if you
look at that at the totality of his
statements over a period of time he has
been whoa yeah we'll see everybody say
we'll see what happens see what happens
we had a lot on the cutting room floor I
don't think that the president is going
to overreact yeah because the North
Koreans need this summit a lot more than
president Trump does so he can sit back
yeah wait and I think the president
Trump was critical of President Obama's
approach to negotiating with Iran
because President Obama made it look
like he was more desperate for the deal
than the Iranian right so it looked like
even if I'm sure the Obama team is gonna
would disagree with the outcome but if
it looked like we were more interested
in getting this done and rushing it
through at the end that's not actually
happening here especially it's just the
second year at the beginning of the
second year for president Trump the
other key factor here is the South
Koreans I know that the Chinese are
really important but the South Koreans
want this more than anything and
president moon is going to be coming to
the White House on Tuesday so the
president will have a chance to meet
with him face-to-face I did think it was
a good thing that president moon said we
are not going to stop these drills with
the United States because that says to
kim jeong-hoon that he's gonna have to
come to the table and i bet that he will
mmm Jesse do you have any theories
behind this I do they don't involve
Dennis Rodman but I think what's
happening he's flexing and paws
shirring to make it look like maximum
pressure didn't bring him to the
negotiating table but in fact it did
bring him there because we had
unilateral sanctions we just slapped on
he brought the UN to make sure they have
the blockade over certain vessels the
fuel was drying up they'd had limited
access to capital so that was all good
so that was the truth of why this has
happened yes he did say some good things
he said we're gonna give the hostages
back we're going to destroy this nuclear
testing site and satellite imagery
proves that it is being decommissioned
right now although there could have been
an accident that already decommissioned
that we have heard and you know so good
things were happening I don't like the
media coming in now and and almost in
Glee that there was a hiccup towards
peace right just to hurt the president
and to act like the president has been
punked here when I think the last couple
of presidents had actually been pumped
yeah gave up nothing and like he said
and you showed in the montage anything
could happen he said something
interesting about John Bolton he said
John Bolton was repugnant this is a guy
that I think burns his uncle's and acid
so to call Bolton repugnant was
hilarious I think what you said before I
would wear that like a badge of honor
him drawing on a shirt and be prancing a
registry that's true and I think what he
was referring to his Bolton had come in
and said we should deal with North Korea
like we dealt with Libya and what
happened in Libya they gave up all of
their nuclear stuff to us and then a
couple years later we invaded and killed
him so that's why he was a little upset
well we LED from behind
I trust you enjoy this view much better
[Laughter]
hey what's your take on all of this you
know I don't think the summit is the
be-all and end-all
I think everyone you know expected oh
this summit it's a good photo op you see
them shaking hands they're sitting down
at the table but the ultimate goal is
for disarmament and I think kim
jeong-hoon ultimately thought he was
holding all the cards he could say well
well I don't like Bolton and well I'm
not gonna do this if you expect me to
disarm and he's not holding all the
cards anymore because now he's dealing
with someone who
has a pretty strong history of being a
tough negotiator I just want to remind
the media though when your president is
going up against kim jeong-hoon you
should be rooting for your that's a
pretty across-the-board type of thing
not surprising their behavior but I
think Donald Trump should stay tough I
think he's doing exactly what he should
be doing is she's just completely
unfettered by this whole thing and say
look my end goal is the same I'm gonna
be tough on you I'm not gonna stop
talking about human rights violation
just because you think that's something
we shouldn't be talking about and I'm
gonna stay true to American values and
American principles and be strong
through this whole thing and that's the
best he can do and you know what if the
summit doesn't happen we're not gonna
change our philosophy or the way we
handle this because we're the United
States of America and that's how we roll
well you were telling me in the
greenroom that Donald Trump in a sense
already won oh yeah prance around people
with you know call the cops you know
what I'm struck by here is that you guys
say oh it's that liberal press that
seems to be the lighting in the moment
or suggestion this might not come off
and to my mind it's the conservative
media that was so quick to say you know
what this guy's gonna get a Nobel Peace
Prize this will be his signature foreign
affairs accomplishment and it seemed to
me like that was a little bit
prematurity because I think he's had a
tough week I know it's not going to be
agreed upon at this table but you think
about what happened this week in terms
of pulling out of the Iran deal which is
not popular in with the American people
that a fantastic move so whatever you
want to say popular with the people
number two the effort to move the
embassy to Jerusalem again lots of debts
and I know again you guys have a
different point of view Hamas whatever
you want to say but I'm just saying very
controversial I like to chime again
because I acknowledge that you guys are
smart then the third point is the thing
about you know ZTE this Chinese company
where he's off on his own and it's like
what's going on so here comes this
motion at this moment and I agree with
you Jedidiah and Greg and Jesse and Dana
Americans should be rooting for
president Trump to do something here
because North Korea is a threat to world
peace
do not want those people to have a
nuclear weapon but the thing about it is
and this is my concern is that I think
world leaders now think they can play
Donald Trump they can give them a big
parade they can flatter him after you
tell em they love is just a sample is
about Israel and Iran you yet that's a
contradiction how's that because those
show that you can't play okay look at
the Paris treaty no but wait you wanted
to say that and what an example would be
that you had McCrone and Merc rates and
Boris Johnson came to the United States
and said ask the president please don't
pull out of the Iran deal and he did it
anyway the same cast of characters and
and more on the Paris climate Accords it
was kind of the same deal so I think
that flattery might get you good press
with the president but it doesn't
necessarily get you the results that you
want no but I think in this case the
idea is that he and again the
conservative media are so hungry for the
Nobel Prize that I think someone like
Kim Jong on is saying oh well if that's
the case boy he really doesn't want to
miss this meeting he needs it more than
I do
and therefore if I say cancel your joint
military exercises President Trump will
be under pressure to do it we'll see
what happens we're not hungry for the
Peace Prize whan we're hungry for peace
nice trophy to shove in the left space
[Applause]
Peace Prize was a participation getting
played with signing onto a deal like the
Iran deal which actually wound up
helping them and you know was a minor
band-aid temporarily and didn't
ultimately fix which is that the issue
of denuclearization and what that means
is the key issue yeah and I know I
actually that's why I'm skeptical on
what if there will actually be an agree
because he's good buying time makes a
nuclearization and like if we're gonna
give economic aid I want to know well
who's gonna get that economic aid is it
the people or is it his regime and the
cronies you know there's a lot to be not
that great point though about the
Spectrum's because even if they agree to
the denuclearization let's say we're all
on the same page everybody shakes hands
and leaves the table then how do you
guarantee that the international
inspectors not not the self inspection
this is the point we got to move on we
got to move on but this is the point we
are all skeptical and we in we have a
president who's skeptical